talk about stimulus so he says
it's not gonna uh i don't support it and
we're not gonna do it until i get
elected
the economy the market drops right then
the next day he says
he's considering it what happens the
market goes up 1.9 the dow jones goes up
1.9 percent yeah
530 points snp gain 58 et cetera et
cetera
and then day after democratic lead house
panel argues congress should break up
the largest tech companies on anti-trust
president trump's full uh uh of tweets
uh when he went what 20 tweets before 8
a.m something like that he was sending a
bunch of tweets
so the stimulus here's a basic thing
about what do you mean you're not going
to do the stimulus
here's how it works if he says i'm not
going to do the stimulus until after i
get elected you know what happens
he's not going to get elected because
there's one card
he has to be able to keep the next 30
days if he's going to get elected you
know what that is the economy the
economy
if he passes the stimulus people get
money you know what people don't like
they don't like change people don't like
change how did bush get elected they
reelected the second time even the
people that couldn't stand him he still
got reelected
even the people that couldn't stand
obama he still got reelected even the
people that couldn't stand out clinton
he still got elected
you realize the last four presidents
have all been two-termed the last time
we had a one-term president was
bush senior so um
i think the stimulus is probably going
to be coming up here very soon
the 1200 i am if i am sent a standalone
bill for
1200 they will go out to our great
people immediately i'm ready to sign
right now trump tweeted on tuesday night
well i give him credit he's
as adamant about flipping and his
enthusiasm about paying the money now
that he was for
not being in favor on monday but write
the checks then if that's what it takes
to tell you but i tell you start the
process you know what the bigger do you
know what the bigger story is here's
what the bigger story is
here's what the bigger story is the
bigger story is yesterday
kamala harris used the scariest word
that i
hate to hear scares the hell out of me
when i hear them debates you know what
it is
if your family makes less than a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars a year
everything
you're going to get a community college
for free on the state
yeah if you have any student loan what
joe biden did is he's going to take ten
thousand
dollars off them i was gonna bring that
up okay so then free free free right
okay
you know what trump is endorsing he's
endorsing
money all free money yeah so this aoc
thing yeah
guess what aos is gonna say look at this
here's how capitalists are number one
capitalism they want capitalism for
others socialism for themselves
but guess what they should what she's
gonna say now these capitalists are
secretly socialists
all they care about is money and she's
right because
this is a socialistic program to come
out with things like this
so long term you know who loses he's
going to pass the stimulus back
long term do you know who loses the
capitalists lose long term
because now they have to do this or else
i don't think so okay i i think this is
a desperate
uh attempt in the final days to do what
you have to do to win
he can flip the script if he gets
reelected and this is not his policy
it's a socialistic program back to back
it's another way of saying hey i'll give
you money if you vote for me
it is a robin hood uh i think it's like
throwing a hail mary in a football game
i think
something you normally i don't agree
with you dude i don't disagree with you
i'm fully with you
but i'm telling you right now the same
thing there is the fact that
you yourself are endorsing a socialistic
not you
you yourself are endorsing the
socialistic program so i'm just telling
you
gradually gradually when somebody push
you know the whole thing about you put a
frog and you've heard this before you've
put a frog in a
bowl and you boil the water and if you
boil it slowly
it won't know that it's getting to 212
degrees before it dies
as opposed to dropping into the hospital
jump out immediately you're right
you know i'm cool with him doing
whatever it takes right now in the final
26 days i'll tell you what i mean
chairman of the fed jerome powell came
out and said we need another round of
stimulus
straight up yeah he's came out and said
that that same day trump said
no more stimulus uh trump has one thing
going for him
one thing his ace in the hole is
if the economy is doing well he has a
chance for reelection
if everything stays the same my friends
we're going to be looking at a new
president in 2020
okay he i don't know why democrats would
at this point in the game
send out more stimulus checks why
wouldn't they just wait another month
until after the election here
he should pray that he cuts a deal in
the next month to send checks to people
to curry favor for a vote he should want
that the fact that he says no more
checks
doesn't help him that's why someone
probably said dude what are you doing
flip court and the next day boom change
his course